[Música]
ante una sesión conjunta del Congreso de
Estados Unidos el presidente ucraniano
bolodimir zelensky agradeció el apoyo
financiero dado por la Unión Americana a
su país durante la Guerra abogó por más
fondos y armamento calificándolo no como
caridad sino como una inversión en la
seguridad global
la nueva presidenta de Perú Dina
boluarte presentó a su nuevo gabinete
será paritario y en el destaca el
abogado Alberto otarola como Primer
Ministro culpado desde la izquierda de
las 20 muertes en las protestas tras el
encarcelamiento de Pedro Castillo
preocupa el estado de salud del Astro
del fútbol brasileño Pelé a sus 82 años
lleva tres semanas hospitalizado en Sao
Paulo y los médicos informaron este
miércoles que está recibiendo cuidados
relacionados con disfunciones renales y
cardíacas ampliamos desde Brasil
Bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
France 24 dedicado a las principales
noticias del continente americano Mi
nombre es Rodrigo sedano y es un gusto
acompañarlos comenzamos en Estados
Unidos el presidente de Ucrania bolodin
mercedensky intervino ante una sesión
conjunta del Congreso de ese país
recibió una ovación de pie por parte de
los legisladores de ambos partidos y
entregó al congreso una bandera
ucraniana con las firmas de soldados en
el campo de batalla Al iniciar su
discurso celensky agradeció a todos los
estadounidenses que resaltó que su país
ha resistido en contra de todas las
expectativas ante la agresión rusa
calificó al gobierno de Moscú de
terrorista y denunció la colaboración de
Irán en el conflicto
en contra de todos los pronósticos y
todos los escenarios planteados Ucrania
no cayó Ucrania está viva y pateando la
tiranía rusa ha perdido su control sobre
nosotros y sé otra cosa importante los
rusos tendrán la oportunidad de ser
libres Solo cuando venzan al kremlin en
su mente
sin embargo el principal objetivo de
zelens que al dirigirse al congreso de
Estados Unidos será garantizar la
continuidad del apoyo económico y
militar para su país en medio de la
Guerra el presidente ucraniano le retiró
a los congresistas que su dinero no es
caridad sino una inversión en la
seguridad del mundo
la asistencia financiera es también muy
importante y me gustaría agradecerles
Muchas gracias gracias por los paquetes
financieros que ya nos han dado y por
los que quizás vayan a aprobar sobre los
que están decidiendo su dinero no es
caridad es una inversión en la seguridad
y democracia global que manejamos con la
mayor responsabilidad posible
anteriormente de la esquí se reunió con
Joe biden quien trasladó al líder
ucraniano su deseo de que la guerra
acabe con una paz justa una paz que para
hacer en esquí significa no comprometer
la integridad territorial de Ucrania en
conferencia de prensa vaivén confirmó un
paquete de ayuda por 1850 millones de
dólares que incluye misiles antiaéreos
Patriot para Ucrania zelensky agradeció
el apoyo y reiteró la importancia de
dichos misiles para la defensa aérea de
su país sin embargo el entrenamiento
para el manejo de este sistema en
Ucrania tomará a un tiempo
hoy estoy anunciando el siguiente
paquete de asistencia en materia de
seguridad para Ucrania un paquete de
1850 millones de dólares en asistencia
que incluye transferencias directas y
equipos que Ucrania necesita así como
contratos para suministrar munición que
Ucrania necesitará en los próximos meses
para su artillería sus tanques y sus
lanzacohetes
crítico para estas nuevas capacidades
como municiones aéreas de alta precisión
el paquete incluirá una batería de
misiles para cuya operación entrenaremos
a las tropas ucranianas
el fundador y ex director de la
plataforma de criptomonedas ftx acusado
de fraude en Estados Unidos ha sido
extraditado desde Bahamas los fiscales
estadounidenses acusaron al hombre de 30
años entre otros cargos de robar miles
de millones en activos para tapar las
pérdidas que tenía fondo de cobertura a
la media research en total se le imputan
ocho cargos que incluyen fraude
electrónico lavado de dinero y violación
de las leyes de financiación de campañas
políticas
y en Perú la presidenta Dina boluarte
presentó a su nuevo gabinete una semana
después de haber tomado juramento al
anterior esto cuando las relaciones con
México pasan por su peor momento con la
familia de Pedro Castillo llegando en
calidad de asilo al país Azteca más
detalles con lluís Muñoz segarra un
nuevo gabinete para la presidenta en
funciones de Perú será paritario y
destaca el nuevo Primer Ministro es el
abogado Alberto otárola quien ejercía
como ministro de defensa un nombramiento
criticado por congresistas de izquierda
pues lo culpan de las más de 20 muertes
que han dejado varios días de protestas
no voy a darle la confianza a un
gabinete que de nuevo no tiene nada que
solo representa el continuismo puro y
que carga sobre sus hombros 27 muertes
en sus primeras intervenciones otarola
arremetió contra el gobierno de México
pidiendo al presidente López Obrador que
deje de referirse a los asuntos internos
del país suramericano amlo Aunque
descartó romper relaciones fue muy
crítico
después de que Perú declarase persona no
ingrata al embajador mexicano y pidiera
su salida del país lamentar
la decisión que tomó
el gobierno
de
Perú
Un gobierno muy cuestionado por la
represión
las relaciones pasan por un momento
difícil y la familia del expresidente
Pedro Castillo ya ha llegado a México
bajo asilo político después de tratar de
disolver El Congreso Castillo fue
destituido y encarcelado un 85% de los
peruanos pide nuevas elecciones y el
congreso aprobó un proyecto para
adelantarlas a abril de 2024 Pero hay
quienes piden que sean antes 32 millones
de peruanos están pidiendo que haga
elecciones en seis meses o cuatro o seis
meses a lo mucho son muchos los que
siguen exigiendo la renuncia de Dina
boluarte y la liberación de Castillo la
presidenta ha asegurado que se mantendrá
firme en el cargo por lo que la crisis
peruana no parece que cederá pronto
la policía nacional colombiana informó
que un ciudadano venezolano fue detenido
en Caracas en relación con el asesinato
del fiscal paraguayo Marcelo pechi
recordemos que el fiscal fue asesinado a
balazos el pasado mayo en barú una isla
cercana a la ciudad colombiana de
Cartagena cuando disfrutaba de su luna
de miel fue comunicada por parte de
somóloga en Venezuela sobre la privación
de la libertad de Gabriel Carlos Luis
Salinas Mendoza un ciudadano venezolano
quien ha sido vinculado a una
investigación por el homicidio del
fiscal Marcelo pechi fiscal paraguayo
este ciudadano venezolano Fue capturado
por unidad de la Policía Nacional en
Caracas la noche anterior gracias a la
circular azul que fue expedida por la
oficina de Interpol Colombia con base en
la investigación de la fiscalía general
de la nación y nos vamos ahora hasta
Brasil porque las noticias respecto al
estado de salud del Astro brasileño
Edson arantes donashimento más conocido
como Pelé son preocupantes la leyenda
del fútbol 82 años y va tres semanas
hospitalizado en Sao Paulo y sus médicos
informaron que está recibiendo cuidado
relacionados con disfunciones renales y
cardíacas Vamos hasta Brasil con nuestra
corresponsal Valeria sakone quien nos da
más detalles sobre su estado de salud
empeoralizado de salud del rey del
fútbol de 82 años el último boletín
médico habla de una progresión de la
enfermedad oncológica y cita
disfunciones renales y cardíacas que
requieren más cuidados pelea de momento
está en un cuarto común no está
recibiendo cuidados intensivos pero
recordamos que está hospitalizado en San
Pablo desde el 29 de noviembre para
tratar un cáncer de colon y una
infección respiratoria el último boletín
médico era del 12 de diciembre hablaba
de una mejora de su estado de salud
especialmente de la infección
respiratoria sin embargo hoy sus hijas
han acudido a las redes sociales para
decir que no van a poder celebrar la
Navidad que van a tener que pasarla en
el hospital y han agradecido el apoyo de
los fans porque Pelé es considerado
realmente el rey del fútbol en este país
y hay una auténtica veneración por el
exjugador recordamos también que pelea
ha estado muy activo desde su cuarto de
hospital durante todos los mundiales el
sábado pasado publicó una carta abierta
de sus redes sociales en la que hablaba
de sueños de amor y lamentaba la
exclusión de la canariña de la selección
de fútbol de Brasil de los mundiales
cerramos este Informativo en Argentina
tras la victoria de su selección de
fútbol en el mundial de Qatar Messi ya
tiene un mural con su icónica foto
levantando la copa del mundo está
ubicado en Buenos Aires y ha sido
realizado por el artista Maxi bañasco el
artista conocido por sus murales
realistas con pintura en aerosol saltó a
la fama por otro Mural del también gran
ídolo de Argentina Diego Armando
Maradona
hasta aquí las noticias sigan conectados
a France 24 y France 24.com
[Música]